Ampel eine gemeinsame Lösung zu finden
für die notwendige Änderung des
deutschen Wahlgesetzes sind leider vor
wenigen Minuten gescheitert
ich habe den Versuch unternommen und der
war sehr ernst gemeint die
ampelfraktionen doch noch einmal kurz
vor der Abstimmung darum zu bitten
diese Abstimmung noch einmal um zwei
Wochen in die nächste Sitzungswoche zu
vertagen denn es ist in dieser Woche
noch etwas Zusätzliches geschehen was
wir so nicht vorausgesehen haben richtig
ist dass wir immer verfassungsrechtliche
Bedenken gegen die grundmandatsklausel
hatten
aber die Abschaffung der Grundmann das
Klausel löst jetzt ein anderes
verfassungsrechtliches Problem aus und
es ist nicht nur ein
verfassungsrechtliches Problem dies ist
ein zutiefst demokratisches und
politisches Problem
ich habe es gerade unten so gesagt
wiederhole es noch einmal die Mechanik
die die Koalition jetzt im
Bundeswahlgesetz beschlossen hat wird
dazu führen dass in ganzen Landesteilen
der Bundesrepublik Deutschland
wahlkreismandate nicht mehr eingenommen
werden können weil jede Partei die in
Zukunft noch im Deutschen Bundestag
vertreten sein will im gesamten
Bundesgebiet der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland mindestens fünf Prozent der
Stimmen erhalten muss
und das hat eine noch mal völlig andere
Qualität gegenüber dem ohnehin schon
zweifelhaften versucht der Ampel
wahlkreismandate gesondert
zuteilungsbedürftig zu machen jetzt kann
es passieren und das ist bei Weitem
nicht nur Bayern das kann auch in Teilen
Ostdeutschlands passieren das kann in
Stadtstaaten passieren das kann im
Grunde in jedem Teil der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland passieren dass regionale
Parteien
praktisch ausgenommen werden von der
Wählbarkeit in die in den Bundestag in
den Bundestag der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wenn sie nicht bundesweit
mindestens fünf Prozent der Stimmen
erreichen und das ist etwas was nach
meiner festen Überzeugung nicht nur
verfassungsrechtlich angreifbar ist das
ist das eine
viel tiefgreifender ist die Wirkung auf
das Vertrauen der Wählerinnen und Wähler
in die Demokratie unseres Landes die
Wählerinnen und Wähler in Deutschland
wählen
Wahlkreisabgeordnete und dann politische
Parteien selbstverständlich steht das in
einem Zusammenhang miteinander aber wenn
die gewählten Wahlkreisabgeordneten dann
ihrem Mandat im Deutschen Bundestag
nicht mehr antreten können weil selbst
jede regionale Partei in Deutschland
insgesamt fünf Prozent der Stimmen
erreichen muss dann ist das eine so
schwere Beschädigung des Vertrauens in
unsere Demokratie dass ich hier auch als
Parteivorsitzender der CDU sage jenseits
aller verfassungsrechtlichen Fragen wir
werden uns ich werde mich mit einer
solchen Wahlrechtsreform mit einer
solchen Veränderung der Spielregeln
unserer Demokratie nicht abfinden und
wir werden jede Gelegenheit nutzen die
uns in Zukunft gegeben sein wird dies
wieder zu korrigieren
gesund dass eine Verkleinerung des
Deutschen Bundestages in unserem
bestehenden Wahlsystem sehr schwierig
ist aber wir waren immer bereit uns
diesen Schwierigkeiten zu stellen wir
haben bis in die letzten Tage hinein
Gespräche mit der Koalition geführt sie
sind leider nicht zu einem gemeinsamen
Ergebnis bekommen ich bedaure das
ausdrücklich und ich hoffe dass wir es
wenigstens in der längeren Perspektive
wieder korrigiert bekommen dieses von
der Ampel heute beschlossene Wahlgesetz
für die Bundesrepublik Deutschland kann
und darf so wie es verabschiedet worden
ist kein Bestand haben herzlichen Dank
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
wir wollen eine
Reduzierung der Größe des Deutschen
Bundestags
aber sie muss
verfassungsfest sein
sie muss mit der
gelebten Demokratie und den vergangenen
Jahrzehnten der gelegten Demokratie in
Deutschland in Einklang sein
und sie darf nicht
einseitig missbraucht werden
um die
ampelkoalitionen die ampelfraktionen zu
bevorzugen
was wir heute erlebt haben ist eine
bewusste Manipulation des Wahlrechts
zugunsten der ampelfraktionen
das schafft einen großen Schaden
übrigens auch für die Zusammenarbeit in
diesem Parlament
wir haben den ampelfraktionen in den
letzten Tagen immer wieder mitgeteilt
dass diese offensichtliche
handstreichartige Veränderungen in ihren
eigenen Vorschlägen die am vergangenen
Wochenende entstanden sind
weder ausdiskutiert noch ausreichend
geprüft noch aus unserer Sicht überhaupt
machbar sind sowohl was die
demokratischen Grundlagen anbelangt als
auch was das
Verfassungsrecht insbesondere im
anbelangt
deswegen wird uns dieser dieses Ergebnis
heute lange lange beschäftigen nicht nur
juristisch sondern auch in der Frage wie
sich die Zusammenarbeit in diesem
Parlament zwischen den Fraktionen weiter
gestalten wird
die Ampel schnitzt sich ein Wahlrecht
das ausschließlich zu ihren Gunsten ist
und das übrigens gegen die fachliche
Beratung auch ihre eigenen
Rechtsexperten wie man heute lesen kann
und deswegen kann man gegen so ein
Wahlrecht gegen so eine Manipulation des
Wahlrechts als Opposition auch nur
gerichtlich vorgehen
es ist richtig jetzt das
Verfassungsgericht auch anzurufen
der Freistaat Bayern wird das tun
und wir werden als Fraktion darüber
beraten wie wir in diesem Fall auch
Vorgehen es ist aber klar dass das
Verfassungsgericht an dieser Stelle auch
angerufen werden muss weil so ein
Wahlrecht so eine Manipulation das
Wahlrechts darf keine Anwendung bei
einer Bundestagswahl finden wir machen
noch ein paar Fragen Frau mentgen vom
RnB bitte
wir werden darüber in der nächsten
Sitzungswoche beraten ich werde der
Fraktion vorschlagen dass wir eine
verfahrene Normenkontrolle beim
Bundesverfassungsgericht beantragen das
erfordert die Beantragung durch
ein Viertel der Mitglieder des Deutschen
Bundestages dieses eine viertel haben
wir in der Bundestagsfraktion der CDU
CSU und ich gehe auch davon aus dass
sich alle Kolleginnen und Kollegen
diesem Antrag anschließen das ist ein
abgeordnetenrecht das ist kein
fraktionsrecht das ist ein Rechte das
aus der Mittel aus der Mitte des
Verfassungsorgans Bundesrepublik
Deutschland des Bundestages heraus
besteht und Alexander und ich werden
dass der Bundestagsfraktion vorschlagen
ja
dann die Dame von der ARD bitte
hatten wir heute auch ausgeführt dass
vor allen Dingen die Änderungen in
dieser Woche den
unbetrifft ja vor allen Dingen die
Abschaffung der grundmandatenklausel
wäre jetzt nur in dem hypothetischen
Falle der Änderungsantrag wieder vom
Tisch wäre das etwas wo sie hätten
mitgehen können oder könnten sie
ansonsten vielleicht mal skizzieren wie
ein Wahlrecht aussehen könnte dass sie
zustimmungsfähig finden wir haben der
Ampel zwei Vorschläge gemacht und sind
mit dem Ampel Vorschlag selbst sehr
konstruktiv umgegangen wir haben der
Ampel vorgeschlagen ein echtes zwei
stimmenwahlrecht in Deutschland zu
nutzen das hat die Ampel noch nicht
einmal beraten geschweige denn ernsthaft
geprüft wir haben der Ampel dann
vorgeschlagen im bestehenden System zur
Vermeidung dieser großen Zahl der
Übergang Mandate eine entsprechende
Änderung vorzunehmen in der Zahl der
Wahlkreise nicht bei 280 zu bleiben wie
wir sie heute haben sondern sogar auf
170 herunter zu gehen dann die Zahl der
Wahlkreis Mandate zu ergänzen um die
listenmandate insgesamt um 350 das hätte
bedeuten dass wir einen Bundestag gehabt
hätten der 3630 Abgeordnete umfasst
hätte also ziemlich genau dort gelandet
wäre wo die Ampel jetzt auch ist wir
haben vorgeschlagen Überhang
ausgleichslose Überhangmandate
zuzulassen in einer begrenzten Form so
wie das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist ja
auch erlaubt das hat die Ampel alles
abgelehnt es ist schwierig hier ein
Kompromiss zu finden wenn man dieses
personalisierte Verhältniswahlrecht
angesichts des veränderten
wählerverhaltens in der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland beibehalten will ich möchte
nur trotzdem erreichen dass wir das
schaffen und wir sind unverändert bereit
mit der Ampel hier auch über Kompromisse
zu reden ich habe meine und unsere
Kompromissbereitschaft auch in meiner
kurzen Intervention zum Schluss der
Debatte hier auch noch mal unterstrichen
das ist ernst gemeint
wir haben den vergangenen Wochen ist es
richtig wir haben in den vergangenen
Wochen Gespräche geführt nicht nur in
den vergangenen Tagen aber in den
vergangenen Tagen ist es noch mal
besonders schwierig geworden durch diese
handstreichartigen Veränderungen die
offensichtlich am Samstagabend dann
zwischen den ampelfraktionen
stattgefunden haben wir haben in den
Gesprächen vorher darauf hingewiesen
dass die Situation des bei jeder
Bundestagswahl zukünftig eine
zweistellige Zahl von direkt gewählten
Abgeordneten nicht mehr in den Deutschen
Bundestag einziehen wird etwas ist das
so nicht unsere Zustimmung haben kann
dafür muss man eine andere Lösung finden
aber auch da war die Ampel nicht bereit
eine entsprechende Vereinbarung zu
treffen zumindestens haben wir
abschließend nicht die Chance erkennen
können eine Vereinbarung zu finden und
es wäre Leute die Möglichkeit noch mal
gewesen nachdem offensichtlich ja auch
durch die Fachleute der Ampel die ihre
Meinung dass dies alles nicht nur
schwierig sondern höchst problematisch
ist bekräftigt haben
verfassungsrechtlich höchst
problematisch ist bekräftigt haben in
eine weitere Diskussion mit uns
einzusteigen
den Mut der Mut hat offensichtlich den
ampelkollegen heute gefehlt die eigenen
Probleme die sie vielleicht jetzt
erkannt haben in den letzten zwei drei
Tagen noch mal zu überdenken mit uns zu
prüfen noch mal einen Anlauf zu machen
dass man sich nicht in der Lage sah
heute zu sagen wir können die dritte
Lesung wäre die zweite gewesen wir
können die dritte Lesung Verschieben auf
die nächste Sitzungswoche die in zwei
Wochen stattfindet und uns diese Zeit
der Beratung zu nehmen dass zeigt
offensichtlich die Bedenken der Ampel
dass wenn sie noch mal darüber beraten
in den eigenen Reihen die Zustimmung
eher kleiner wird wir hätten das auch
erwartet aber dem Ergebnis hätte es
sicher gedient dann noch eine letzte
Frage ich kann leider das Gesicht nicht
erkennen von dem Herrn da drüben
würden sie möglicherweise bei einer
nächsten Regierungsbeteiligung diese
Reform auch im Parlament rückabwickeln
ich habe das gerade gesagt und ich will
das noch mal unterstreichen und das sage
ich jetzt hier nicht als Vorsitzender
der Bundestagsfraktion sondern ich sage
das als Vorsitzender der CDU
Deutschlands diese Reform ist so wie sie
heute von der Ampel verabschiedet worden
ist für uns absolut inakzeptabel und wir
werden bei der nächsten
Regierungsbeteiligung wenn es nicht bis
dahin ohne hin geändert worden ist
dann werden wir bei der nächsten
Regierungsbeteiligung darauf drängen
dass das geändert wird das Wahlkreise in
großer Zahl in Deutschland gewonnen
werden können ohne dass diejenigen die
sie gewonnen haben anschließend einen
Sitz im Bundestag einnehmen ist nicht
hinnehmbar und deswegen muss das auch
wieder geändert werden noch mal ich weiß
dass das schwierig ist aber wir sind
bereit uns dieser schwierigen Debatte zu
stellen sagt dass diese Wahlrechts
Manipulation darf keine Anwendung bei
einer Bundestagswahl finden deswegen
werden wir die Klage beim
Verfassungsgericht einreichen wir hoffen
sehr dass dieses Verfassungsgericht in
den nächsten Monaten dann dazu auch eine
Entscheidung das heißt vor der
Bundestagswahl der nächsten eine
Entscheidung dazu trifft und dann wird
es nicht möglich sein dass so ein
Wahlrecht überhaupt zur Anwendung kommt
und ansonsten werden wir jede
Gelegenheit nutzen auch diesen
wahlrechtsmanipulationsbox wieder zu
vielen Dank für Ihr Koch vielen Dank
schönes Wochenende allerseits
die Reaktion von Alexander Dobrindt und
Friedrich Merz nachdem die ampelfraktion
SPD Grüne und FDP hier mit ihrer
Mehrheit die Wahlrechtsreform im
Bundestag abschließend
zugestimmt haben das ganze muss jetzt
natürlich auch noch durch den Bundesrat
wobei das dort nicht zustimmungs